first I want to start with
congratulations on the movie
um films like this are tough to get made
I appreciate that uh that it was made
and uh I just want to say you know uh
thanks and anyway but before we get into
that I like throwing a curve at the
beginning for all three of you if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them watching and watch
the first thing I want them watching
um
uh I did an independent film years ago
called the Mexicano it was like the
first feature film I ever did so I want
them to start at the beginning uh uh it
was a shot in Queens New York for under
200 000 uh and it's very much an
independent film he premiered to Tribeca
in 2009 uh but that's a good start I
think
all right zero shoot
um honestly I did a lot of indie films
but I probably wouldn't ask anyone to
watch those I'd probably say start with
King Richard it's not a huge role but
the movie's so beautiful and I was a
tennis pro for nine years so it means a
lot to me to be a part of that tennis
movie
um so yeah King Richard
and for me uh I agree with you by the
way
um for me it would be uh the show that
kind of
um gave me my first big break uh in the
industry and uh that was only murders in
the building and uh loved working with
all those people on that show
um Smoochy solve it I'm curious uh
getting ready for this project I'm I
would imagine uh you put some pressure
on yourself to make sure you delivered
authentic performances they've been um
some great films like a full metal
jacket and jar head and other things to
talk about I'm just curious are you
watching projects like that before
stepping on set and how much are you
sort of avoiding that and just looking
at what's in the script I mean for me
Fullmetal jackets one of the films I've
probably watched the most in my life so
I was uh that film was definitely in in
my
sort of in my in the Zeitgeist when I
was uh um thinking about this project
for sure
I don't know about you guys for me uh to
answer your question yes and no uh I
feel like because this story is so
unique
um and it's not full on war it's almost
like getting you ready for that
um
for me though to kind of channel that
kind of uh culture Ambiance uh Jarhead
is one of my favorite films so I watched
that a whole bunch before
um but at the same time also being aware
and sensitive to what's yeah what's the
script what's this film about
I um I haven't seen either of those
movies
and also just the nature of the
character being so fresh to the Marines
and it all being so new and and you know
novel and sort of daunting
kind of felt like it mirrored you know
taking on the task of joining the you
know joining the film and the project
and how new everything was in general so
I didn't really feel like other than you
know learning what I needed to for the
character as far as like learning what
you know other things that are Marine
heavy or military heavy I just felt like
it would all happen naturally if I took
it in as we shot it so I didn't really
watch anything I love learning about
like the behind the scenes and the
making of movies so for soon to be fans
of this what do you think would surprise
them to learn about the actual making of
the film Mississippi is hot as hell oh
man oh man oh no I'll let you guys kind
of touch on the on the artistic I guess
uh part of it right like the the
culmination of all that
I mean yeah filming in Mississippi was
really interesting because we were in
Jackson which there's not a whole lot to
do in Jackson
um coming from New York City uh so we
were kind of sequestered in our hotel
and and I think the the the form of the
uh the process making it Elegance really
set us up to kind of mirror uh the boot
camp experience I mean he really made a
point of dividing the drill instructors
and the recruits and like so there
wasn't a lot of socializing at the
beginning between both sets and uh that
really kind of informed the work I think
in a major way but just being in
Mississippi because we're you know again
there's not a lot to do we're all just
kind of piled in together and it kind of
mirrors it kind of mirrored the boot
camp experience in some way I think
um adding to that when I first met Raul
and Nicholas Logan another one of the
incredible drill instructors I went up
to them so cheered like hey what's up
guys and they both looked at me looked
at each other and were kind of like hey
hey and then I was like oh and then I
found out they were told not to interact
with us but at first I was like dang all
right
don't fraternize yeah but he was they
were told not to do that so that's
probably something that would be fun to
find out about the behind the scenes
sort of building the dynamic of that so
absolutely I think Mississippi
um as a whole kind of played a big part
to kind of set
set everything set the tone for the film
because
you know Mississippi is a Southern state
and it's got it's got its own history as
well
um so I think within uh the weather and
kind of the the the habitat that was
kind of built
um I feel like it was very it was very
easy at times to like Channel and like
tap into the realism of of all of it
um within what was in the script so it
was once again it was very hot there was
also there was also shot
um at a police academy so it was like on
an actual uh like where people were
really training and uh we were given the
opportunity to go and see some of their
training happen before the film started
sort of to understand kind of the
intensity of it all and sort of how
everything moves as a unit and how the
dynamic between being a recruit and
being a an instructor or whichever role
you ended up playing uh played out in
real time on those grounds even while we
were shooting there would be people
training or running and like the whole
time it was happening around us while we
were also performing it which was really
a fascinating experience shout out to uh
Jones was kind of our instructor in your
life she kind of got us ready and
prepared for um all the drills we had to
do and to like really have the full
posture of a marine and and kind of get
our head uh in the right space yeah uh
Iman I have a just an individual
question for you I have to know what it
was like uh Landing the role in this in
Star Wars uh you're playing a very
popular character it means a lot to a
lot of people
um I I don't actually have any like
confirmation about it and there's really
not much more for me to do towards it
but I do love how many people are like
stoked for me to play that that would be
so cool and I I appreciate the people
putting the pictures and
um we'll just kind of see what happens
but I appreciate that thank you on that
note I really mean it sincerely congrats
on this movie you guys did really great
work thank you thank you thank you very
much Steve